ああああああ
はいクリエイター目立ってきましたよね皆さん僕の家もそうですけどいろんな神社の
暖房を使っています暖房
もちろん皆さんの日もそうだと思うんですけども寒くなってくると暖房器具を使います
猫ストーブ
こたつヒーター相続の暖房級で部屋を暖めると思うんですけどもおりたちは唯一後食べ
られない部屋がある
何かって
ぞと異例だそういうことで素晴らしいを気づいてしまったいろんな部屋を暖めることが
できるがそう
トイレだけは温めることができないそうだら普通の部屋は全然あた食べれるんですよ
立っを入れだけを温められないいやお金持ちの人はそうかもしれませんでもね一般的な
家庭では寝ないんですよというに暖房器具などないんじゃないじゃあそうない
すごい3回くらい行ったな
ユチョン勃起うかなので我々はトリマートイレに2つの老化も寒い中を入れてなく寒い
んですよ僕の実家のそれでは覚めしこの家のトイレも様に遠いですね
村いっしょ今回はですね何とかして暖かいトイレを作ろうと思いまして難しいですよ
狭いから薬を飛びつけるわけにもいかないし
一つも受けないストーブも受けないどうしようじゃあ
古代はここにあった難しい大量の回路でお風呂場にサーバを作ったと思うんですけども
それのちょっと会場版で今回はこちらのはめ替えの30個入りを準備しました12時間
継続しますトイレのだ
を全部跳ね返るてこう埋め尽くすことによってと指の中12時間暖房状態になります
こうすることで打って再起ぼくのいえば友達や後輩がよく来るんで僕は復縁で僕の家に
来皆さんがトイレを温かくすごいいいじゃないですか
いいと思いますよ素晴らしい企画なるから1000個あるんですけどもこれを全部
トイレの壁とか床とかに全部貼って本会は暖かいトイレ暖かく
トイレができるトイレを作ろうと思いますエアをくまなく
あった模様ず狙い攻
くろよん
ん
では最後車買っていきます is えええええええ
ちゃーん
これの旋回であります
[音楽]
ゼーゼーヒューヒュー
もう中だぜそのだよあとこれ100回するんだぞ
でも言うよ
魚津50
[音楽]
船長それで室へここ待ってくださいねそれは世界なんで終わった会の小原れているから
富士郎に
ウィッ余っあったかねスゴイねこれでは
うわぁ
あっただけあったっけ8倍で4番だったかすごい
温度だと思われますザバカといるするんで
また続き困ってみたい室にこもってみたいんだよ思ってみます
やばいよこれ苦しいてかなきゃ男子が薄い
大丈夫やっぱねサーな人をなぜみたいにちょっとヤバいようん
ヤバイぞ
で大丈夫ちょっと待ってっ
やばいこれ
た皆さん
同じような者さん
始め大丈夫
って言え a
言えばさあそう
いいいい
ee
しています
意識飛んでたん
[音楽]
やばいです回路が絶賛すがねこの辺ねー
ここばせよマギープロさーん
はーふわぁ
ダガーン
始め山正樹さあ
酸素酸素ですはじめさん
ああいいいい
早く0
ずっとあゼッター
を
これ大丈夫かここずっと付いただがまずはまじゃないよこれ
これはもう外でよやばいなーやばいはこれますぞやばい
ちょっとやばいマジでやばい来なく天付き
小技やんだ
[音楽]
ん
チャンスがあった
[音楽]
た姫えええ
よし行こう今5面を作らせくださいありがとうございます本当にあるんですっ
me
[音楽]
バッハ